you you also have like
other businesses and other like and and
you're like your your family is just
stunning you're uh how did you meet your
wife twitter
no you didn't yeah are you ready really
did she slide into your are you saying
are you saying twitter or are you saying
tinder twitter twitter yeah it was
before tinder you know what i meant how
do you meet somebody on you slid into
her dm i didn't i did i did but how do
you even see people don't really put
pictures on twitter this was like before
instagram you know what i mean like and
this was you know i that month she was
like um
miss september and playboy in 2013
and i just followed her actually like i
didn't even like wait wait wait wait but
because of that's right that's right i'm
like this
this is who i'm meant to be with i'm not
even kidding you bought the magazine
yeah like that's how like and the truth
of the story was i woke up that morning
was like i
am meant to marry a playmate and i'm
like okay who are the latest playmates
and then she was september of that month
and i swear to god i just was like this
is who i meant to marry and it i just
followed her she screenshot it and said
hello new friend and it's like whoa whoa
whoa what are we doing here you know
what i mean and then
like like in her
sort of profile like it was her dream to
swim with sharks and pet a tiger and i'm
like i think this is amazing because
i've been attacked by both
wow that i could probably be your life
coach
and then
you know then as i'm like
like you know uh it goes to texting
right right and then i'm
like um it's time to set a date you know
i'm like do you want to set a date you
know like let's meet we never took me on
the phone to meet and so she i'm like
you want to get together on friday she's
like what do you want to do i looked
through like her like all of her posts
and she was posting about like a
a
kennel and like riverside that was going
to euthanize all the dogs and i'm like
riverside's like two and a half hours
from here i said why don't we get a
helicopter and go to riverside and
rescue some puppies oh my god half hours
later
she's like she's like
sure and i'm like what see alex my son
is listening
look so then i had to get a helicopter
and i never even met i never even talked
to her on the phone right it was like it
was like an episode of catfish it was
like man like is this like a double
episode
but you had the magazine you had the
play button i don't know i mean you just
you never know you know what i mean like
in the game in september
yeah this is all in a week's time so i'm
driving to go pick her up and i'm like
i'm like uh or the week i'm going in
she'd post about dayton ohio and i'm
like are you
like what do you have connected to
dayton ohio where i'm born and raised oh
i thought she was talking about you i'm
dating ohio no and she's like oh my
that's where my
my my
my entire mom's family's from my mom
lives there with my brother right now
and i'm like oh my god this is destiny
right so i've always had this like
feeling that i was meant to marry
someone connected to hawaii right don't
know why hawaii hawaii right this really
how are we getting from ohio look i
don't know so i'm going to pick her up
right i still haven't talked to her on
the phone and i'm like i got a
helicopter waiting in van nuys you know
a block from here i'm like going to pick
her up i'm like don't even care about
hawaii why are you even thinking this
what does that even mean this is why is
this even inside you this is so random
say hello super awkward she gets in my
fancy you know fan you know i pick her
up in the ferrari trying to be like you
know this is how we roll out here we're
going to get the helicopter she sits
down i don't even have 10 seconds of
conversation i asked do you have any
connection hawaii
and she's like oh um i'm
i um
i guess my my sister lives there with my
grandparents right now and i'm like oh
that that's pretty solid that's awesome
for sure this is who i meant to marry so
then
we're up in this helicopter and then she
begins to tell me a story that she is a
that she was like diagnosed with a
um rare blood disease called aplasty
anemia and she was given six months to
live when she was 10
and that all she wanted to do was swim
with dolphins and she went and make a
wish uh granted her her wish to go swim
with dolphins and she went and swam with
dolphins in hawaii and when she swam
with the dolphins she told herself that
she wasn't going to let herself die and
that she was going to experience things
like this forever
and man i could have shed a tear on the
spot and i'm like this is my wife you
know what i mean and
and literally from like that point
forward like i have just had this
extraordinary
amazing incredible existence how long
before you got married from that date oh
like a year yeah so september again
yeah i got married
got married september 19th did you
really yeah
and then and and now you have two kids
two amazing kids you know and most
people when they say who are you meant
to marry it's like oh i want someone
who's funny i want someone you just were
looking for a whole a connection
i don't play me i don't even have any
idea look how beautiful she is oh that's
why it didn't have anything to do with
hawaii and her being a playmate it was
because you saw her and she's gorgeous
and she wants to rescue puppies can you
go to her instagram no go to can you go
to mayans better too by the way thank
you you look great thank you
does
very
bother you at all no no jealousy that
she is in in in playboy and other people
who are now listening to this are
downloading playboy pictures of your
wife i i mean maybe look over here to
the right here to the right look at this
oh she's stuck this is this is on
saturday she just won
mrs queen of the world this weekend can
you
are you yeah can you go go to the video
slide over to the video so you can see
like let's see this so look like and
here's your hair play the audio
[Applause]
so you're you're married to the queen of
the world that's it
that's just stunning
flew the whole family out where was that
where is the queen of the world pageant
held uh
town new jersey morristown new jersey
the center of the
world and what an extraordinary
experience look how happy your daughter
looks wow
they're they're in the chaos can i go
home can i go home her mommy's a
princess oh and look at you with the
white suit on matching with the sun we
went out and we did it big flew straight
into morristown ran into chrysler
pacifica drove straight up the tarmac to
the hotel
it was an extraordinary weekend so as
the queen of the world pat and jean out
there my parents and my sisters there
brought everybody that's fantastic cause
this is what it's about experiencing
life
[Music]